Voiceover: So where we had left off,
Benjamin Franklin had pretty
much established himself
as a successful printer and, I guess,
content producer, writer if you will.
Voiceover: Media mogul.
Voiceover: Media mogul in Philadelphia.
We're in the 1730s,
we're starting to enter
the kind of the late 1730s now.
At what point does he
make the transition from,
I guess, media mogul
to statesman or leader?
Voiceover: Well it starts off when he was
just a young assistant printer.
When he was only 21,
he starts little club,
sort of a civic club,
almost like a Rotary or Kiwanis club,
for middle-class tradesmen and artisans
and the shopkeepers of Philadelphia.
He calls it the Leather Apron Club,
sometimes known as the Junto.
The Leather Apron Club because it was not
for the rich or elite or
he famous business owners,
nor for the poor working man.
It was for the people
who put on leather aprons
every morning and opened up a shop
and stood there behind the counter.
That Leather Apron Club
becomes a foundation,
as he becomes a successful businessman,
for all of his civic endeavors.
He was sort of, the club trained people
in a way, to be civic leaders.
They made a list of the virtues you needed
to have to be a good civic leader,
such as industry and
honesty and frugality.
Franklin was so geeky he put it on a chart
and every week he would
mark how well he did
on each of those virtues.
At one point he had mastered
all 12 of the virtues.
He showed it to the other
people in the Leather Apron Club
and one of them said,
"Hey Franklin, you're missing a virtue
"you might want to try."
Franklin says, "What's that?"
and the friend says, "Humility,
"you might want to try
that one for a change."
Franklin said, "I was never very good
"at the virtue of humility,
"but I was good at the pretense of it.
"I could fake it very well."
Here is the important thing by Franklin.
This is what he writes, he says,
"I learned that the pretense of humility
"was just as useful as the reality of it
"because it made you listen
to the person next to you,
"try to find the common ground,
"and that was the essence of
the middle-class democracy
"we were trying to create."
Voiceover: Fascinating. So
how does this gravitate into,
I mean I'm sure they're meeting,
they're making lists of traits
Voiceover: Yeah, sort of
every Friday they meet,
and besides making traits
they make a list of things
that can improve the community
until they come up with plans.
There's the first library, the first,
sort of, lending library of Philadelphia.
I think that was like in 1731.
He does a lending library.
That's even before the
first Poor Richard's.
So that was the first thing they'd do,
because he believed that
the young tradesmen,
the rich people had their
own private libraries,
but there should be a free library,
one that people could borrow the books.
Then they'd do a street sweeping corps
and they'd do a militia.
They'd do an academy for
the education of youth
that becomes the
University of Pennsylvania.
They'd do an insurance company
for widows and orphans.
You know his mother is somewhat baffled
because she's an old-fashioned
Puritan and says,
"You can only get to heaven
through God's grace alone,
"not through good works."
and Franklin says, "Well I'd
rather have it said of me
"that he lived usefully
than that he died rich,
"and I believe that the
best way to be in favor
"of the good Lord is to do things
"for all of his fellow
creatures that he created."
So that was Franklin's credo,
which is "Lets do good civic works,"
they created a hospital even,
"in order to help our fellow man,
because that's what the
good Lord wanted us to do."
Voiceover: Fascinating.